(bell ringing)
- Mike worked at
McDonald's for eight years.
And I think we all know why
he doesn't work there anymore.
They took away all
the incentives.
I mean, they tore down
all the playgrounds.
(audience laughing)
- Really lucky that
both your opponents
look like pedophiles.
(audience laughing)
You know, people are
asking me tonight
if I'm gonna put
Sarah in her place.
She's a 38-year-old
woman in comedy.
There isn't one.
(audience laughing)
- That's amazing, that's funny.
Mike hates sports, obviously.
For someone who
doesn't like sports,
you sure do look
a lot like a 49er.
Oh, It's Canada, (bleep) me.
(audience laughing)
Goddamn it.
- I'm sure someone will after.
(audience laughing)
Sarah's vagina is like a bar.
It's dank, full of drunk dicks,
and children are
immediately forced to leave.
(audience laughing)
- Don't clap at that.
Don't clap at that.
That's ridiculous.
Like that joke was like
everyone tampon I've ever used.
Despite what I've been
told, I'm never shocked.
(audience laughing)
I don't know, go ahead.
Sure, why not?
Nobody cares.
No, I care.
- Sarah, you know,
people think she's slut,
she's actually a real prude.
She won't even put
out new material.
(audience laughing)
- [Voiceover] Last
joke of the battle.
- Wow, thank you Dirt Vonnegut,
that was really funny.
(audience laughing)
Oh man.
I don't know if
you guys know this,
but Mike sucked a
dick in college.
He's very open about it.
That means between the
two of us on stage,
we both know how
to swallow a ball,
but he doesn't know
how to throw one.
(audience laughing)
- Sarah does lots of
tours for the troops.
Finally, a drone they send
overseas that never kills.
(audience laughing)